Halon is with us in Canada
hi Kailin how are you I'm very good are
you better than I deserve
what's up I have a question for you guys
I'm looking to move out
I have no debts I've got about 15
thousand dollars in savings and I was
looking around on real estate websites
and I found a mobile home that's for
$50,000 it's in kind of disarray but I
have experience in renovating so I could
renovate it or should I save up another
year and buy a condo for 185,000 how old
are you I'm 20 okay um in your
experience have you observed mobile
homes value changes and if you were to
guess and say this $50,000 mobile home
if you put 10,000 at renovate it you got
$60,000 in it what do you think it'll be
worth in 10 years I've done too much
research into that part of the of the
home on Kaitlyn I mean what's your
what's your gut feeling tell you that
that mobile home is gonna do is you're
gonna go up in value or down in value
probably not very much in value probably
not gonna go up in value very much not
gonna go up at all but I'm just yeah I'm
probably gonna go up but I'm just trying
to go down as quick as I can right it's
gonna go down in value it's gonna go
down in value okay
it's a collar you sleep in okay and so
for a piece of real estate we don't buy
real estate that we know has a known
track record of going down in value okay
they simply don't go up in value and so
that's why we don't buy them it's that
simple it's not because we're snobs it's
not because we don't like them it's not
because the construction technique it's
not because they're how nice they are
they just don't go up in value they go
down in value you're going the wrong way
so I mean the Christian outweighed
Kaylin I mean my friend like you said
weight by condo this is something that's
going to actually appreciate I think
that's the better plan for you and
long haul my friend you want to make
decisions on your finances that the 10
year from now version of you is smiling
of yes whatever the decision is you know
you're getting ready to turn this amount
of money into less money or more money
and over ten years more please
yeah I'll take more if that does and you
know here's the thing it's a great
question Kalin
whether you're twenty whether you're
forty or whether you're sixty it's still
a great question to bring up you know we
did a when I first start doing the show
Chris years ago I saw a study that
showed that wealthy people the
especially people people who have built
their wealth have a different planning
window a different mentality when
they're making a financial decision the
Bible says where there is no vision the
people perish and so what the study
showed was was that wealthy people when
they're making a decision have a
tendency to ask themselves how is this
purchase or this investment gonna treat
me ten years or twenty years from now
and people who are broke and remain
broke poor and remain poor
tend to ask tend to think in short
planning windows like thank God it's
Friday oh god it's Monday that's right
and so it adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good so
it turns out wealthy people just don't
Yolo that's right you only live once
nope god I've got to have a party on the
weekend yeah well not to say that
wealthy people don't have fun not to say
that they don't enjoy themselves
it's not to say they don't do these
things and as in the process of building
wealth which they don't live in a cave
collect Linnton crippled upon triple
coupon Thursday but they but they do
think about their purchases over longer
periods of time and even for that matter
when they're sitting there and saying
okay we're going to go on a trip and is
this trip something when we look back on
it that's going to be a high-quality
memory
building trip ten years from now or is
this just the booze cruise for the
weekend
which you don't even remember what
happens right you know and so it's a
different mentality no you're absolutely
when you go on those trips or where you
see the wealthy people when you go on
the other trips or where you see the
others the other kind of yeah no you're
absolutely right Dave and that mentality
you know it's something that in looking
at it I would think wow how is it
possible to outgrow that or to shake it
off and it really is just a decision it
is a decision and you know I'm seeing
people you know the debt-free screamer
that we had on earlier who you know
talked about her family tree how they
didn't do well with money but for her
she decided and I just I love the power
in that that regardless of how you were
raised you can decide and you can pursue
yep just like that